police releasing video this afternoon of  an officer involved shooting from last  tuesday it happened that evening 11 p.m  at a convenience store on pecos near  kerry police were looking for  34-year-old maurice parker  suspected of shooting into a car earlier  that day when police located parker he  was at work at a convenience store  you can see in this video body cam  footage and surveillance video from the  store parker was given verbal commands  to put his hands above his head  at first police say he complied  mr parker reached into his waistband and  produced a handgun  and turned toward the officers  simultaneously  sergeant perry detective pappas  detective mcgill  and detective stafford fired their  weapons striking mr parker  a total of 13 rounds fired parker died  at the scene